Oh what is a sick [ __ ] it's an
Australian term it's very endearing help
me out here
what is a sick [ __ ] sick [ __ ] and
definition of a gun there's sick [ __ ]
mad [ __ ]
are there any other kind of Consular
[ __ ] cut oh so you want to be a sick
[ __ ] but not a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Music]
Hetal our New Zealand
copycat lines
[Music]
you probably don't need too much more of
an inch either they you commit to the
massage chain because Steve oh yeah
hello we're talking about I would join
you and sorry that was something my nose
is all [ __ ] both immature
[Music]
when they on and what I meant
a lot about the stage when I go anywhere
when I do anything so I've taken a photo
with every city
[Applause]
that's just now I do
[Music]
[Applause]
safe country yes - what's your name I
know now real sweet I feel like a Paul
Newman let's pull jam to Singapore holy
[ __ ] do you not want to miss the trip to
Singapore that's why you better
subscribe right here and if you haven't
been watching all of these darn vlog
videos I've been making on tour you are
nuts and you better watch the last one
in me right down here
shoot better watch mom because it kick
ass what else I don't know it's the age
of the selfie that's for [ __ ] sure